on the second day of the temporary
ceasefire Hamas released 13 Israeli
captives and four Tha
Nationals after more than a 7-hour delay
the Red Cross facilitated their transfer
to the Rafa Crossing where they were
then brought back into Israeli
territory in exchange the Israelis
released 39 Palestinian women and
children from their
jails among them is
who spent 8 years in an Israeli prison
for a charge she
[Music]
denies my wounds are visible and my
struggles I don't want to talk about
them the yearning for family this is the
price the prisoners
pay Israeli authorities headed by a
far-right government have banned
celebrations for Palestinian prisoners
returning home Israeli police deployed
in large numbers around their homes in
occupied East Jerusalem and even used
Force to disperse the
scenes Saturday's release comes on the
heels of the carefully coordinated
operation on Friday in which 13 Israeli
and 11 foreign National captives from
Thailand and the Philippines were
released and in the occupied West Bank
scenes of
joy as crowds gathered to welcome this
second batch of newly released pal inian
prisoners joy and relief for reunited
families who've endured terrible
suffering now I am very happy but I
always say it it's for the people of
Gaza we feel something is missing
something making us sad inside and
because we don't know if all the
prisoners would be released or not we
would always be worried are they going
to be released or not those ones who are
with life sentences or long long
sentences but their new found Freedom
comes at a heavy price and their
happiness is Tainted by the killing of
over 14,000 Palestinians in the Gaza
Strip at the hands of the Israeli
Army we give the message to the people
of Gaza stay steadfast we are always
with you in our heart
the price for Glory is very high but we
are people who can create miracles from
our
pain but in the meantime over the Skies
of Gaza an unfamiliar silence as the
temporary truce holds for now ham Al
jaaz occupied East
Jerusalem make sure to subscribe to our
channel to get the latest news from Al
jazer